the state of Louisiana will send letters
today to 37,000 people living in nursing
homes and group homes warning them they
could be evicted because of Medicaid
cuts a budget shortfall of more than 600
million dollars means the state may no
longer be able to pay for Medicaid
programs david beg no is at a nursing
facility in Baton Rouge with the
potential impact David good morning John
good morning you know the story is
getting a lot of play on social media
from people who cannot understand why
the state of Louisiana can't handle its
business better than threatening drastic
cuts like this 66 of the people who live
at this nursing home where we are gonna
get one of those letters saying you got
to find another place to live by July
1st now look a lot of people say the
governor is just threatening folks and
trying to scare them so we came to Baton
Rouge to talk to the governor a lead GOP
legislator but we started by talking to
somebody who could be affected
I was yeah was there a reason sit and
don't do it Toussaint Hartnett is one of
about 37,000 people who may lose their
Medicaid eligibility and be evicted
medicaid pays 70% of his room and board
at this nursing home in Baton Rouge he's
70 years old and he's been living with
MS for 22 years I think those bathroom
come out the bed some bathe myself but
over on the home
I require for everything according to
the Louisiana nursing home Association
the budget cuts include a Medicaid
program that provides health care
services for approximately 80% of
nursing facility residents across the
state for those people who are saying
what all you doing is engaging in scare
tactics no I'm following the law if they
had done their job in February these
notices wouldn't be going out Democrat
John bel Edwards is Louisiana's governor
I've said clearly over and over again
these are not cuts that I want to see
implemented well with all due respect
you were the one who first proposed them
right well understand I have a 1.4
billion dollars less in revenue I have a
constitutional obligation to deliver a
balanced budget proposal and I called
him in the special session the next
month to fix it and they haven't they
haven't Republican state representative
J Cameron Henry is head of the
Appropriations Committee in the
Louisiana House what does the GOP want
from the government I think with the GOP
one from the governor is a budget that
is sustainable long term to not have to
come back every year with scare tactics
to say the sky is falling the skies fall
what do you say to the jaded Louisiana
resident who says listen they always say
it's the end of the world but they
always miraculously find a fix what I'm
looking for the fix I believe we will
find it but what we're talking about are
things that are fact-based things that
are required by law and if we don't fix
these things will happen so here's the
catch if the state of Louisiana makes
these cuts the federal government has to
first approve them the state can't cut
Medicaid funding without the feds
approving it so Galle if the state does
it but the feds say no we don't approve
then the state of Louisiana has got to
find another place to make cuts
let's hope they work that out thank you
very much David